hello my name is mathias from data tab
and in this video i would like to
show you how you can easily and directly
calculate descriptive statistics online with datatec okay but
first of all what are descriptive
statistics usually you want to make
a statement about a population
but since it is not
possible to collect the data from the entire
population, a random sample is used, i.e. outside 6 o’clock and overall, you have a random
sample drawing, the descriptive statistics are
now used to describe exactly this sample
, so you use the
descriptive statistics, you can only do one
statement about this sample
does not make about the total population to now describe
this in the discussed statistics
this thick sample
, for example, values ​​such as the
mean value, the variance, the
standard deviation, the minimum value, the
maximum value have also tables
the frequency or cross
table therefore  sometimes we also
like to use graphics in bar charts or
a line chart
but now we want to calculate
the descriptive statistics for our own sample. for
this we go to
date up de then click on statistics
calculator and then click on descriptive
statistics to add our own data
use let's just click on
table teachers now you can
just copy your own deeds here to this
table with strong tsv rain in
this case we'll just stick to
the example data the data is
copied to table 1 and see the variable name of
the first
row  we list all the
variables down here now we just need to
click on the variable
with which we want to calculate the descriptive statistics
depending on how many are clicked there
are different
possibilities
let's just start and we
click on age now we can decide for
that  let age output the mean value
Send this to the modal value, the variance and so
on and so forth
and we then get a
table below with exactly the values.
Now we can also click on the
weight and this table is
simply expanded by the weight. Furthermore,
we get down here  a
table that describes this data,
for example, a histogram, a
box plot and a line diagram
, for example, if we now also include the
variable gender, then we can
now have it displayed how the
mean value depends on the age of the
gender, i.e. male and female
is here  divided in the table we
can also show how often
male and female occurs i.e. 6 x
6 x and we see a histogram down here and we can also
display a bar chart
for male and female and a boxer
, for example, is only a nominal
variable selects gets a very
simple frequent as chart can that
the frequentc
Since the percent is output the valid percent we
just click on a nominal variable
we get a cross table where we have
entered the sex on one side
and
the location on the other axis as well as
graphics we get in bar charts showing the
exact location  and the gender applies
this we can of course also
swap and then have
different forms of representation how
we want to graphically represent these two variants of
course you can
discuss a lot of other things with the app calculate statistics
i would say you just get
your own actions into it now the
waiting ones  and just
see what you can calculate everything
I hope you liked the video here
bye and see you next time